in other news tonight several animals  are dead and three people are hurt after  a fire caused by fireworks  this happened just before 5 a.m near  cary and civic center  the north las vegas fire department says  nine cats and two dogs died in the fire  three people were taken to the hospital  and treated for smoke inhalation  a total of eight people are without a  place to live tonight  according to the fire department two  structures and multiple cars  went up in flames my dad said that he  felt really bad because  he knew that he knew the kids and the  father because they would always walk  through here  in the morning to go drop off their kids  from school and that  he feels bad that they have no place to  stay  north las vegas fire says in recent  weeks there have been an  increase of firework related fires with  at least one happening last sunday  damages for this fire are estimated at  half a million dollars